bienvenue à Jurassic Park quand j'ai vu le
premier Jurassic Park je suis juste parti en
ayant l'esprit époustouflé c'est comme si le cinéma
avait été réinventé juste devant moi quand
je pensais que j'étais comme oh mec je veux être
dans ce film je veux être dans un  habiller
appartement ça nous a donné envie de devenir
cinéastes devenir conteurs devenir
acteurs il y avait un film révolutionnaire je
pensais que l'utilisation de la technologie
et du nouveau cg et voir les dinosaures
prendre vie pour la première fois c'était extraordinaire quand j'ai regardé pour la première fois
c'était effrayant  mec ça fait encore peur aujourd'hui
j'ai un souvenir très précis de la sortie de Jurassic
Park le dernier jour d'
école et il y a un sentiment qui va de
pair avec celui d'être seul dans une
salle de cinéma et d'être transporté pour
porter Jurassic Park vous emmène
voir Jurassic  le monde prend vie, c'est
presque comme voir Jurassic Park devenir
réalité maintenant, il y a un véritable
parc à thème de dinosaures fonctionnel que 20 000 personnes visitent par
jour
chaque fois que nous avons dévoilé une nouvelle
fréquentation d'attraction  a dopé
c'était un fantôme génial sur la
route d'origine qu'aucun des autres films n'a jamais
osé voyager les yeux sur moi une bonne
entreprise a estimé que la modification génétique
augmenterait le facteur wow a été conçu pour
être plus grand que le t-rex que nous venons d'
aller faire un  nouveau dinosaure probablement pas une
bonne idée de ce qui est arrivé au frère
qu'elle a mangé
vous avez une coupe après la sortie de confinement
qui était vraiment bien d'être ici
faire du monde jurassique est fou mais c'est
aussi très émouvant où tout le monde sourit en
prenant un moment pour se regarder  autre
et très légèrement sous notre souffle faire
ce que nous faisons ici c'est
fou c'est tellement amusant tu sais à quel point c'est amusant
c'est tellement amusant ouais nous avons un peu l'impression que
nous nous sommes faufilés dans la fête tout le monde a eu
ce moment où j'ai  vu ce petit
enfant dans leurs yeux,
il y a beaucoup de surprises dans le
monde jurassique et ma confiance était si élevée et
ce que notre réalisateur a appelé allait vous
permettre d'agir